welcome to this video round one
of the candidates tournament encounter
mansisk
and we're looking at the game
medyarov against tupalov
um yeah we have the two players
competing in the first round that
qualified through the grand prix series
a series of strong gm tournaments
where players got points
per per tournament and over span of four
five six tournaments i'm not quite sure
the best two players scoring the most
points were topalov and mamijarov so
those two
play in the first round
mumbairov playing d4 and that's his
usual opening move he can play e4 but
he mostly is a d4 player it has pretty
good results with it so
this was to be expected and to pilot
place the slav
which is not a surprise he's played the
slav for for a long time
often um
going to uh to semi slav waters
but
topalov has a wide opening repertoire he
also
could have played the king's indian or
the grunfeld or whatever he's got
many things that he can play
okay
knight bd2 that's um a slide
yeah yeah the surprise is the wrong word
because my mediarov has played this move
before so
um tupalov actually um could have
predicted this exact position to
appear
with some
some degree of certainty
but okay you never know if the opponent
is repeating the moves that he had
played in earlier games he might come up
with something new early
okay knight bd2 what's the idea of the
move yeah it's very apparent idea you
want to
to cover the c4 point
the phone is hanging black might take it
um of course if you look at
the main move
i'm actually pressing the button to
go back one move and it's doing nothing
here
what is happening
okay
i'm not sure what the software
was doing there if you play move like
that which is the absolute mainland
black can take which introduces the
classical slav
and then you need to
invest some time to get the pawn back
like e3 b5 is not getting the pawn back
so easy
you'll get it back later but need to
spend time on a4
main move is a4 here and it's entirely
different to knight bd2 after knight bd2
you're absolutely sure that black will
not
capture early because
this is obviously very helpful for white
the knight
gets a good post on c4 looking at
important squares and
it frees up the bishop again which is
the main drawback of course of knight
bd2 it blocks the c1 bishop and
therefore that's not in its super active
move
but it's an interesting move in
regards to some specific continuations
if you
think about what i said um just two
minutes ago that topalov plays the
semi-sloth then e6 here is a move that
black yeah should think twice about
because of two things
white might try queen c2 intending to go
e4 in one go
not like e3 and then e4 but in one move
this is
quite nice for white
and here there also is the move g3
which probably will transpose to a
catalan
and where black has played a very early
move c6 and
not sure that you want to do that i mean
you can play the closed catalan but it's
not the walk in the park
so e6 is probably not so great here
it's not losing or anything but yeah
it's uh it does not really um
yeah
seem to be the most precise way to play
black can play bishop f5
which is in fact what i recommended in a
or will recommend when it will be
released in a video for the icc which i
produce in german language where
where i present a repertoire for black
based on the slav bishop f5 is the main
move
one point is that after queen b3
this is hanging the move
oh i'm sorry
white plays this first i forgot about
that
to attack the bishop and if it retreats
now white has the tricky idea queen b3
to answer queen b6 which is a mistake
with queen h3
a very funny line
threatening queen c8 almost with a mate
but
it will win the important b7 pawn
yeah and the second idea is of course
that
um
white is able to to take on g6 and
damage a damaged black spawn structure
you cannot recapture with the
h-bond and something like that is pretty
terrible really
for black
so that's an interesting idea one of the
ideas but okay black black has better
ways to play can go here for example
and be okay that's my recommendation
um grandmaster avruk in his recent book
has bishop e6
also with an okay game topolof is doing
something else and i think what he's
playing is actually a good idea
g6
which white answers with the e3
and
my suspicion is actually that
after this game
white
might
go for g3 more
because um this is also a possible idea
which transposes to the fianchetto
greenfield
um okay white is um committed to this
early knight d2 obviously
but um it still probably
has more bite than what was played in
the game
as mentioned there was um e3 plate
some other software is very slow here
e3 bishop to g7
and um
mission 2 g7
and here um mama jarov played bishop to
d3 and this has been played um a number
of times i think i have
more than 100 games in my my database
something like that
i'm not sure it's doing strange things
this uh the software here
maybe i need to restart it
all right i have restarted
the software and back
i hope that it is uh
more
yeah that it's running more smoothly now
okay as mentioned this has been played
quite a number of times and normally
black has played
castle cm castles castles
and tm
there were when he moves played bishop
g4 for example one idea that writer
might play is if black plays a somewhat
somewhat nothing move like knight to d7
white might
play a b form
and continue to push on the queen side
without running
much risks especially this bishop is not
doing so much
looking at the d4 pawn
this is the old way to play well knight
d7 is a bit passive but i just want to
show the general idea black is um
in comparison relatively passive but
apollo now played the move c5
which is um
maybe surprising to some because well he
has played c6 just a couple of moves ago
but
it's not really mattering so much it
loses it looks like it loses a tempo
but that's not the way to approach such
a such a position or any position in
general you need to judge what's the
best move in the position and okay it's
on c6 but
if
for example if you imagine a position
where you have the the pawn on c7
yeah let's just for argument's sake do
that
yeah i put it
i put this back
uh well black would play c5 in this
position if you ask him what move would
you want to play
so um it doesn't matter if he had played
c6 or not
it's just important to do the right
thing
so um
um
means i need to load this again
so he played c5 and the good thing about
this it immediately attacks the center
and makes sure that this bishop actually
has got something to do
combining pressure on this d4 pawn
and i
actually believe that this is an instant
equalizer for black
um if you look at the what's happening
here
um we can start with um with this move
is this an idea for white
in fact it isn't black um has many uh
possible arts you can even take with the
queen
but um you can also look at this move
but here maybe a fee form
okay so probably probably not but black
can also just take here this is uh no
no problem at all
he will always get this pawn back
in the game he took on c5
and after knight a6
black
will get the pawn back there's very
little doubt
about that
white um cannot cover it with a pawn and
he tried to cover it with a knight
knight b3
this feels very logical the knight on
d2
is obstructing or was obstructing this
bishop anyway so
this
makes lots of sense
my first idea here was yeah why can
black not take here
in fact i think this does not equalize
completely
you have this position like we'll get
get it back here of course
but if you look at at this um type of
position
on why this may be slightly better he's
better developed and
he will get activity with this bishop
here
so this is probably not completely equal
what the pilot did i think is just
better he took on c4
bishop takes check and now we have this
trade on d1 which is very important to
to note that black is playing c5 before
both sides have castle so
you actually get this position with the
king on d1 which is very important and
the whole point is that now knight e4 is
coming
with f2 hanging with the fork
on the rook and the king so
white's move is
almost forced he played king e2
and now black took on c5 so black got
the pawn back
we had this straight and now we can take
stock how to assess this position yeah
black has managed with this quick c5 to
get rid of
the pawns on the d file and the default
on the c and the d file
and
this means it's very important
that
in the in the upcoming moves both sides
will fight for those
two files
but
what you also need to notice look at
this
excellent bishop on g7
this is
very typical for the green fart or
in if you
imagine this with colors reversed for
the catalan
that the bishop on g7 is such a strong
piece that always exerts pressure on the
spawn and makes it difficult for white
to get this bishop out quickly
so um
i think this looks very very decent for
black he's uh very close to being equal
if not already i think what mohamed
yarov is doing is uh is the the best way
to play play bishop to b5 check
which is moving the same piece again yes
but it serves a concrete purpose
this check
lets um black
decide what to do
if yeah well the king move looks very
strange so bishop d7 is
a very natural move i mean it's not
terrible to play this one
but um i mean it's not like losing or
anything
but it feels better to develop your
c8 bishop and now he captured and
the polov actually decided to recapture
with the king
um surprising at first but he wants to
keep it on c5 this night
and does not want to want to retreat it
it
might lead to similar position it took
here
and after the check went back to v8
so um white has gained a bit of time
with this bishop b5 move
he got the the rook into the game early
and
this is actually what makes the position
about equal i think white is somewhat
quicker on the files but black has this
strong bishop on g7
yet rook b1 yes
it's always this pawn
so uh white lends some support to it
and now rook c8
here
the c file certainly a good place
for the rook
bishop d2 you need to develop it
and knight to e4 yeah very
very logical play bishop to b4
yeah it's not that white necessarily
wants to uh
yeah keep the bishop at our costs it
wants he wants to
make sure that this has some activity
on
black's position some pressure
plate f5 now which i like you
open up the f7 square for the king so
that you can connect rooks
it's uh it was difficult otherwise to to
manage that so a good move
and now remember jarrod played knight to
e1
and again i move that i like the knight
here
i mean
is it really doing so much those squares
are protected and it's not clear that
knight d4 is ever going to to
yeah lead to anything
and of course
this is a thread now
white needs to react to it and so it
just covers it and the knight has a good
future on d3 actually i mean good future
it's not brilliant on d3 but
it can be uh maybe improved from d3 one
on f3 it's really doing not much
okay a5 this is a debatable move i think
i am i'm not sure the thing is that
um just in a couple of moves topalov
gets into some trouble
and i don't think that this should
happen
i feel like this is just very equal and
he shouldn't really
be in any trouble
so um
i was asking
whether where the problem was and then
maybe it is really a5 i mean this is a
very active move and typical for tupalov
he is not the kind of person to to to
just sit on his position and uh
improve it slowly and so on he always uh
seeks uh
yeah for a way forward
which makes its uh style attractive to
watch but it's sometimes simply
not a successful style against the right
opponent
um he might run into some some better
yeah counter blows or he weakens his
position while being active and this
might be one of those cases if you look
at this the whole idea is of course yeah
purely dynamics
the piece is attacked
you cannot really take avoid the capture
on a5 let's say move like this it's just
it's just ugly
so y takes and this was uh topalov's
idea played rook a8 now
rook to d5
okay covering it from the side
played b6
yeah that's an interesting way to play
if white now takes
then this is
instantly okay because you get b2
back the next move
so he went back to b4 and now took on a2
so a5 was a tactical idea
to get the rook from c8
where it was looking at the covered c2
square
to um to a2 so it looks like at first
sight like a good rook activation
but um if you look at this in a bit more
detail like here knight d3 was played
this
knight
is nicely positioned to cover this
weakness
and black still has a weakness or even
two he's got e7 as potential weakness
and this is more important b6
the b6 pawn only is is on b6 because
black has played a5
after a5 and the capture there was this
tactical
necessity to play b6 and now you have to
um two weaknesses
here and
yeah it's it feels like
black needs to be precise
here it's not it's not so easy to play
and in fact if we look at this king f7
and rook c1 yeah white is playing
actively as well he wants to
enter here
so i note that bishop b2 rook c2 is very
embarrassing we'll lose a piece
so black cannot do that
and yeah why it has good influence now
on those two important uh
important files so
maybe it's really a5
and maybe we should go back to this
position
once we have finished the
main analysis because i feel like here
it already is a slightly tricky position
for jack look at this
white
really has pressure now it's got e5
for its knight b6 is
attacked by the rook
this already feels tricky
he went back
to a7 probably because the rook is rook
c7
this kind of ideas um it was it was too
much
and
here maybe is the point uh
for white to look for an improvement um
played bishop a3 which is uh
it has some logic of course that keeps
b2 nicely protected
and prepares further action but i think
it has a simple not simple one but
a tactical drawback that immediately
helps black and
we see that later
on what the computer
suggests here is just rook c6
attacking the pawn
the point is or the important thing is
of course that white cannot take because
of this one
with a monster fork
so white wants to do it like that
keeping d5 protected
and then maybe capture on b6 the next
move and here i don't uh don't see a
completely satisfactory
reply for black i think he will lose the
pawn and he can try to fight of course
it's not like
just instantly losing
but
it feels like black has a hard time to
to save this
he will at least suffer being a pawn
down
for example something like that knight
to d7
um
yeah it takes
and then after oops not that
after covering the b2 pawn
we will take
here next black and try for counter play
that's clear something like
check
this can be played
and
it's not uh
like
an
easy win or something but white at least
has won a pawn and can can try to push
in the game he decided for something
else and i don't think that this really
is doing much
oops
hit the wrong button there
he
had a good defense after bishop a3 black
played rook a5 and now up from this
point now i think both sides um
play the absolute best moves um
yeah it
looks at this knight which is
unprotected
and which prevents white from just
grabbing the piece
so what should white do
it's actually
yeah it's um
what um
yarov did is probably the
the yeah the nicest looking way to
to force the draw but um
i think the worst is already over
um
the alternative to rook c7 which is what
he played was to capture
but uh of course here black can also
take with the pawn
and i don't really see black ever losing
at this position it should be
all right you can go to d5 for example
play 6
if you want to cover c7 e6 only if the
knight is attacked computer only gives
wider symbolic edge here so probably
this is all right
he played rook c7 now mommy jaroff
okay this hangs the rook but
it has an idea
after the capture and took apart and to
paul off captured it
there was rookie 7 check
enter king d8 if black goes to f8 we
need to look at all this
a7
check
so this will win
the game easily
must go here
yeah and now white of course has a ton
of checks and yes the draw in hand
and this is what happened actually he
played
knight to f7 check check
you can also go here but note that this
check
this is not working
sc7 gets now
controlled by black's knight
white simply cannot play for wigner he
can what he can try is he can take on on
g7 um he
actually gave those checks and then took
on g7 this is possible to continue for a
moment
note that
if white captures on b5
there's rook takes a3 very important
and it all
gets
exchanged now
with the draw to come
rook g7
and now rook d5 and this is again an
important move to pilot plays the best
defensive moves here this introduces
ideas like rook takes a3 to get the the
knight
and here um
mom jarov
ended the game by
giving this
series of checks
black of course cannot avoid it
check me i mean he can avoid the draw
but uh
not in a way that that will suit him
so at the end a draw which is probably
um relatively fair result
i think mama jarov had something he
maybe um
could have exploited
the weaknesses with this rook c6 idea
and
i
quickly want to go back to the a5
position
what is it that black probably should
play to avoid any any sort of
problem i mean he can really just sit
tight i believe
maybe um yeah well king f7 is
not really helping because you get
there maybe maybe this is an idea to
or bishop d6 even
if you just want to a dead equal
position you can do that
something something like that
and it's it's completely equal
can easily agree a draw yeah the rooks
will come off
as well almost
completely symmetrical
yeah somewhere around here i guess he
had ways to simply kill the game off to
a dead raw but
he played this as usual in the most
active fashion and maybe got into slight
trouble
okay so draw good
or decent start for both players thanks
for watching